[Music]
Britney Spears
she has ruled the Las Vegas Strip for
the last five years and may I say she
looked amazing doing it but now she is
hitting the road and she's only talking
to us about it your piece of meat show
it's going to tour at this summer how do
you keep in shape on tour this round of
shows that we're doing for the tour it's
like they're back to back so each show
is like I don't have any time apart
besides flying my show is a workout in
itself so it kind of keeps you really
strong Britney's been doing serious gym
time to prep for her piece of meet US
and European tour she's practicing new
dance routines and her itty-bitty short
shorts and squeezing in some fun time
with the guy she calls my other half Sam
Ascari who's a pretty darn good workout
partner as well are you like really
careful about what you eat sometimes I'm
like I just want a hamburger but when
I'm in real work mode I want very clean
I like just clean chicken and veggies
like that's it my stomach is so
sensitive I have a steak I'll be since
like sick for three days you're kidding
me mm-hmm what about the burger where
does the burger duty and burgers line
vary okay I have the small burgers from
McDonald's the happy will we're just so
happy that
the 36 year old will do 30 shows and 51
days many concerts are already sold out
your kids get to go on the tour with you
yes the committee they enjoy it you know
the other day my kids Steve and putting
new remixes into my show and stuff and
my son there's one of the new songs on
the radios like mom that's so cool
so I'm putting all these different songs
in my show so they're coming along
[Music]